وبسرعة حقيقية ، كانت
هناك دراسة خرجت من إسرائيل حول
المناعة الطبيعية
وكان العنوان الرئيسي هو أن المناعة الطبيعية
توفر الكثير من الحماية بشكل أفضل حتى
من اللقاحات وحدها ،
فما الذي يجب أن يفعله الناس من ذلك حتى
نتحدث  حول تفويضات اللقاح ،
هناك مكالمات طوال الوقت يقول الناس إنني
مصاب بالفيروس بالفعل أنا محمي
والآن تقول الدراسة ربما أكثر حماية
من اللقاح وحده إذا حصلوا أيضًا
على اللقاح كيف يمكنك جعل القضية
لهم
أنت تعلم أن هذه نقطة جيدة حقًا ،
ليس لدي إجابة صارمة حقًا
بالنسبة لك بشأن هذا الأمر الذي
سنضطر إلى مناقشته فيما
يتعلق بمتانة الاستجابة ، وهو
الشيء الوحيد الذي لم تخبرك به الصحيفة الإسرائيلية
هو ما إذا كانت درجة الحماية من العدوى الطبيعية عالية أم لا ،
فما هي المتانة مقارنة
بمتانة اللقاح ، لذلك من
الممكن تصور أنك مصاب بالعدوى
ولكنك قد لا تكون محميًا من
فترة زمنية غير محددة لذلك
أعتقد أن هذا شيء نحتاج إلى
الجلوس والمناقشة بجدية
لأنك أشرت بشكل مناسب جدًا إلى
أنها مشكلة ويمكن أن يكون هناك
حجة لقول ما قلته